Now that we know how to define methods,
let's see how to call them.
We'll start by filling in the body
of the throw down method.
This method will simulate
a player throwing down a move
rock paper scissors, and simultaneously
generate an opponent's move
in order to create a rock
paper scissors game.
In our case,
an instance of the class RPS game.
The player chooses a move,
rock paper or scissors, and
that move gets passed into
the throwDown method.
First off, we'll take that move and
generate an instance of RPSTurn.
We'll call it playersTurn.
Notice that the Objective C compiler
doesn't infer types the way the Swift
compiler does.
So every time we create a new variable,
we need to first indicate its
type like we're doing here.
Then on the right side, we allocate and
initialize an instance of RPSTurn.
I'd like to dissect the right
side of this statement.
Focus in on this section and
you'll see our first method call.
In-between brackets on the left, we see
the object receiving the method call.
RPSTurn.
And on the right,
we see the method alloc.
But in Objective C, instead of
saying we're calling a method,
we say that we're sending a message.
So the general form for
a method call looks something like this.
In the previous example,
RPSTurn is the receiver and
alloc is the message being
sent to the receiver.
Next, let's zoom out to
the call to end it with move.
On the left,
we see the receiver of the method call,
the space in memory
that's been allocated.
On the right,
we see the method in it with move
followed by the argument players move.
So here's the receiver,
the message and the argument.